so let's continue just recall we went
over the dollar strong protocol like we
raised a couple of questions we were
able to partially answer the first
question and I said you know I saved the
second question how to reduce the round
complexity with randomized protocols to
the the second part okay and let's keep
this question in mind I'm not sure I'm
not going to mention it until like later
on in the talk so for this part let's
now move forward to 2018-2019 right so
what has happened you know blockchains
and decentralized cryptocurrency came
around and of course the first system
was a Bitcoin and Bitcoin like what's
the first to really move consent
distributed consensus to an internet
scale deployment and they're the
essential idea is to have like a
entirely permissionless protocol where
everyone can join and to achieve this
bitcoin relied on proof of work because
I'm imagine not going to talk about
proof of work our permission is because
Rafael is going to talk about it in the
afternoon but what people realized is
that with these proof of work protocols
they're kind of expensive they're not
very nice to the environment so there's
this push towards a new paradigm that we
want to implement proof of stake
protocols rather than proof of work and
there's also like this understanding
that maybe proof of State stake
protocols are economically more robust
than proof of work anyway okay so what
is proof of stake like I guess maybe
some of you have already heard of all
these terms like in proof of stake
improve our work the idea is if I have
computation power that I have
proportional voting power in the
protocol and improve of stake if I have
stake in the cryptocurrency then I have
proportional voting power to the man of
so in order to construct these proof of
stake systems we are actually returning
to our roots like we are actually making
use of permission consensus protocols
assuming existence rpki and we can use
this as a building block to construct
proof of stake cryptocurrency systems so
in fact tomorrow
I think Achilles's talk is going to talk
about proof of stake and before this
talk I'm just going to focus still under
permission the classical setting but I'm
going to talk about modern protocols
that were like recently developed and
specifically I'll talk about direct
block King constructions right in the
first part I talked about one-shot
consensus presenting agreement but now
we want a blockchain we want you know
this linearly order lock that keeps a
publicly available ledger there's a lot
of blocking projects and companies
around that it seems like in the past
five or six years like every company has
been inventing their own consensus
protocol there's a big push from the
crypto community but this the crypto
being the cryptocurrency community so
this actually says something right like
all these companies that actually we
they're reinventing permission consensus
which should be a problem that we
understood from a long time ago but what
this is thing is that the existing
protocols like before cryptocurrency
there may not be good enough for
practical deployment and that's why
there's this big push and the knowledge
about this line of work is kind of a
scattered because it seems like every
company just has a very different
protocol so I'm going to try to at least
somewhat decipher what's going on I want
to present what I think is like a
simplest protocol in this paradigm you
know it would be nice if we can actually
find the protocol that we can the same
protocol that we can implement we can
teach and basically unify this knowledge
don't become clear later I'll explain
all of this okay so let's start with the
blockchain as an abstraction classically
actually plug Qi was studied also in the
distributed systems literature it was
often called state machine replication
essentially we have a set of nodes and
now they not only want to reach
agreement just once they want to
repeatedly reach agreement over time to
establish a linearly order log of
transactions and this log is going to
become the public ledger okay so this is
informal informally speaking I'm going
to formalize these properties a little
later informally speaking we want
consistency and liveness consistency
says that all of the honest nodes must
agree under the lakh people's network
may have different speeds like some your
luck may be a little faster than mine
that's okay our logs have to be prefixes
of each other
liveness says that whenever you know I
want to buy coffee the transaction will
appearing everyone's not very quickly
okay so still you know some of these
nodes can be corrupt so like I said
block she also has been studied for a
long time but previously it was not
called a blockchain which caused a
machine replication and when Bitcoin
came around you know there's this idea
when we do consensus we want to do
batching right we always confirm a block
at the time rather than the transaction
at the time and naturally you know we
have the school name blockchain and all
these Silicon Valley companies actually
for the past decade they have always
deployed state machine replication
protocols often in the crash fault model
actually and the reason why they need to
do so is like for instance in Google
right what they have let's say Google
Wallet Google Wallet is a critical
service like you want to make sure the
service is distributed and replicated on
multiple nodes not just on a single
server because otherwise you'll be
putting too much faith in the single
server but once you start to distribute
the nodes there's
this consistency issue that naturally
comes up like you know this is not like
facebook wall post maybe if you see
something inconsistent from me that
that's not going to be too disastrous
but you know Google Wallet is something
you really want strong consistency okay
so just to formalize the definition I'm
sometimes calling it state machine
replication sometimes calling it Black
team but they are me in the same thing
in this part of the talk if I ever
mention consensus I actually mean a
blockchain okay so like I said the goal
is to agree on an ever-growing log of
transactions and I'm going to use the
following notation the notation isn't
too important it actually won't come up
later on in the talk but it's just here
for specifying the properties formally
so imagining every round T and note I
outputs a lock that's denoted lock I T
so this is note I slog around T and I'm
going to just make a simplifying
assumption like every node is always
going to output the longest final log so
whatever I output it's caught final and
my lock should never shrink so I don't
want to deal with like lock shrinking so
I'm just going to assume the protocol is
nice in the sense that I'm always going
to take a look at the longest final log
I've seen so far and I'll put the
longest okay so now I need to define
consistency and like this again the
execution may be randomized and I want
these properties to hold for output
negligible negligible fraction of the
execution traces and in fact the
protocols we are going to discuss use
only signature and hash function so if
you assume ideal signature and hash like
there's no signature forgery no hash
collision then your you can also just
assume
these properties must hold with
probability one okay
consistency says that any honest notes
log at any time must be prefixes of each
other so specifically for any honest
node I and J J for any round P NP prime
note I slogging round team must be no
prefix of this says is a prefix of must
be no J slogging around a prefix of no J
slogging around T Prime or vice versa
okay and if the two logs are equal we
also say there are prefixes of each
other like this s and so in this
protocol these nodes are receiving
transactions from some environment right
and they want to confirm these
transactions so if an honest node
receive some input I'm using px to you
know the input in some round P then
shortly afterwards like after T
confirmation delay this transaction must
appear in everyone's log every honest
nodes log ok so specifically we can
often call this variable as the
confirmation kind and we may allow the
confirmation time to depend on like
lambda is the security parameter and
it's number of nodes and doubt is the
maximum in our delay okay
so we want to construct a protocol like
this the first thing to observe like
this goes back to your question earlier
why do we care about the blockchain
abstraction right so basically agreement
is single-shot if we assume existence of
PKI
one way to get the blockchain is just by
sequentially composing Byzantine
Agreement does nothing there's nothing
it will violate liveness to receive this
receive input is kind of like there's a
you know you can think of it there's a
memo containing other outstanding
transactions I am obtaining the man pool
from the network all of this imagine
there's this abstract environment that's
giving me them the mantle
so the first thing to observe is like if
we are happy to assume PKI essentially
everyone knows everyone's public-key
then based on ting equipment and
blotching they are kind of equivalent
from a feasibility perspective like for
instance if you have a blockchain it's
very easy to implement basing agreement
because let's say ETA is the sender if I
can just sign a message and post it to
the blockchain and whatever message
that's supposed to first will be the
agreed-upon build so with that you can
realize presenting agreement from a
blockchain and you can also do it the
other way like if you want to construct
a blockchain the simplest conceptually
simplest approach is to just
sequentially compose Byzantine agreement
like Iran I note I is the designated
Center and then you have got a
blockchain in that you know this is fine
the typically we want the clients to be
able to yeah I guess in this formulation
we don't have the notion of clients like
that you can imagine if a client in the
honest
in this formulation we don't have a
notion of a kind but if you let's say
there are observant clients are kind of
like observant notes that don't
participate in the consensus protocol
when naive way to support clients is
they can just ask the notes to let's say
these are consensus notes right so they
can ask the consensus notes to vote on
the block and if you are making like
something like an honest majority
assumption you can just like take the
majority vote out this oh yeah for this
part of the talk I'm going to assume in
fact I'm going to give a protocol that
assumes 2/3 2/3 honest
so except I think for yeah then you have
to also say that to me it's a little
more tricky indeed it's a little more
tricky if it's corrupt majority because
then it's not clear with the observer
like the num consensus note would do
right because you cannot take a majority
vote and if it's like honest majority
the client can somewhat be supported
easily by taking majority vote among the
conservative but this is also very clean
obstruction right if you think of Google
or any company they don't care about
observers they only care about the notes
running gets to agree it's clean I'm
saying it's potentially might be in the
afternoons going to talk about late
joiner so this is the issue of observer
it's also related to people joining late
so that I can't go to a very lengthy
discussion about the modeling like for
instance we had a paper in the paper
that showed like you know the classical
synchronous model is not it's just not a
good model because of this issue because
there's there are observers and people
can join late and people can drop off
line temporarily and you don't want to
like treat armies notes who just happen
to drop off line as corrupt that's like
a completely orthogonal discussion so
therefore now for this talk let's just
assume there are only consensus notes
I'm not going to talk about the notion
of client to make things simple and it's
kind of easy to support a client if you
assume honest majority clients are just
like non-participating observers
okay
so now you can go back and forth between
Byzantine Agreement and state machine
replication or blockchain as long as you
assume PKI right so in one direction if
we know eta is the sender to construct
basing agreement from blockchain it has
to post a sign message to the blockchain
and the first message will count okay
and then to go the other way want to get
the blocks you from presenting equipment
you can sequentially compose presenting
agreement instances and in each instance
everyone rotates to be the sender and
there you will be fine I'm not going to
formally prove this it's kind of easy to
believe and what this is also saying is
that in the corrupt majority setting we
can't just like for instance rely on
total LIVESTRONG to get a synchronous
blockchain protocol tolerating honest
corrupt majority this is not supporting
observer observers or client notes
because this is corrupt majority so it's
things are little more tricky but but
under this notion you can't get a
blockchain without observer you can get
a blockchain okay so this protocol is
nice in the sense like you know it
tolerates many corrupt nodes but it's
kind of slow because every block takes a
linear amount of time to confirm this
may not be what we want to implement in
practice for this reason another
question that was asked in the first
part of the talk so they're kind of
equivalent right so why is this a
meaningful abstraction I guess there are
many answers to this question like one
is from an efficiency perspective and
composing but the natural we took a
blockchain is by sequentially composing
in Byzantine agreement but that may not
be the most efficient construction like
if you try to directly construct the
blockchain protocol it can often be made
more efficient and in fact Hilbert refer
and I had the paper in the previous euro
crypt and we showed like for instance
for some adaptive corruption setting we
can actually buy directly constructing
blockchain we can't get
communication efficiency that's not none
and through composing presenting
agreement so there are results of this
nature and this efficiency is both from
a theoretical and practical perspective
okay and I think Rafael will talk about
other reasons why we need blotching as
an abstraction because like once we have
blockchains we worry about how to
distribute the rewards like we want
notions like game theoretic security
fairness like we want to define notions
like chain quality which may be
difficult to define if you're just
considering single-shot consensus so
I'll leave this to the afternoon but
there are many many reasons why you care
about blockchain itself as an
abstraction ok so just maybe kind of
repeating there are two ways to get a
blockchain construction when it's just
through sequential composition our
basing agreement and the second approach
is what we will focus on in this part of
the talk is to get the direct blockchain
construction and in its direct
blockchain construction it may not be
clear where the boundary between these
single-shot instances are but you cannot
easily extract oh here's a single-shot
instance that here's the second single
shot misses everything streamlined as
you see slightly more cynical view the
first type is the Pazzi and crypto
community the this kind of results of
ensuring authority and STI and in
real-world implementations Alessandro
asked me to provide an interdisciplinary
perspective here so this is an
abstraction that many communities care
about so Alessandro also asked me to
provide a practical like implementers
perspective and consensus so that's why
we are going to focus on this
and you know if we turn back the clock
to ten years ago before Bitcoin before
blockchains
if you wanted to implement like a state
machine replication protocol the go-to
protocols would be things like pbft our
paxos and there are many variants of
these earth protocols like raft I won't
be able to provide an exhaustive
exhaustive list but things have changed
a lot ever since like all these
blockchain companies have started
working on consensus and so hopefully
with this talk you'll be able to see
that we can't get constructions that's
kind of that's what pbft and Byzantine
Paxos do but with much simpler
construction and I don't know if we are
there yet but it would be really nice to
have a unified construction which is
both what we want to implement in
practice and also what we want to teach
I'm trying to make an effort towards
that direction okay so first I will
review how these classical approaches
work pbft Paxos I will pick the simple
part to go over like I'm not going over
any specific product I'm going over this
class of approach generically okay and
then I'm going to say what's kind of
what's complicated about these classical
approaches and I'm going to try to talk
about how to get much simpler
constructions okay first there's some
hideous things to go over we are going
to assume every block has a specific
format this is a slightly modern
perspective it's going to be a chain and
because every block has the parent
blocks hash so once you look at the
block you can immediately bind it to the
prefix the the prefix of the chain just
by looking at the the hash
we are going to assume a plot contains
this sequence number the sequence number
is just like okay what position the
block is in this launching and then it
contains some payload like transaction
okay so here is a very simple and
natural protocol let's go back to this
majority voting idea again like we kind
of looked at it earlier but the specific
variant we looked at didn't quite work
out I'm now going to give a slightly
different variant of this majority
voting idea okay so here the guy in the
middle is caught the proposer some of
these nodes can be corrupted the
proposer itself can be corrupt to
proposer
makes a proposal so this protocol is
going to be repeated for every position
every sequence number in the blockchain
right proposer is going to propose a
block and now everyone is going to vote
on the proposal it has received in this
case the guy proposed an orange block so
if you are honest you are going to cast
an orange vote if you are dishonest you
don't have to follow the protocol you
may vote for other things like this guy
voted for two blue blocks and the vote
is just a signature on the proposal
so now we just basically collect all the
votes and once we collect two-thirds
votes on the same block
we are happy like there's enough
confidence and we believe that this
block is confirmed so in this variant of
the voting protocol we want to count
exactly two-thirds votes and I'm going
to say this very soon we are going to
assume at most less than one-third of
the nodes are correct yeah we know and
it's a PKI everyone knows everyone is
publicly we know who who is
participating in the protocol exactly
who is participating okay I'm going to
assume a strong CPI model where everyone
knows who's participating and everyone
knows who everyone else is probably okay
and so the rest of the talk I'm going to
call a collection of two-thirds votes
and notarization convenient terminology
these votes have to come from distinct
notes okay and the most important thing
about this simple protocol is that the
honest notes must vote to uniquely at
every position let's say we are trying
to agree on the fifth block I'm going to
receive a proposal from the guy in the
center I'm only going to vote on one
thing like if he gives me two
equivocating proposals I'm just going to
vote on the first thing I hear so this
is important for proving consistency and
let me just give a very simple
consistency proof that shows essentially
whatever is confirmed must be unique at
every position okay more concretely
let's just focus down on a specific
position right so imagine each I has
heard 2/3 people voting on the blue
block and maybe Rafal has heard 2/3
people voting on the orange block I want
to show that this must be the same block
right because it is going to come from
this one and Rafael is going to come
from this one so let's look at the 2/3
voters that have voted on the blue block
and the 2/3 voters that have voted on
the orange the interception must be
large as long as there are fewer than
1/3 notes corrupt because 2/3 2/3 is
like
what thirds minus n so the interception
must contain at least one-third number
of notes
the intersection must be large
regardless of how many people are
corrupt but because few people are
corrupt
there must be an honest guy in the
intersection the intersection must be at
least one-third less than when they're
corrupt so there must be an honest guy
in there interception and remember that
this honest guy is going to vote
uniquely and the only reason that this
could have happened is these two are the
same block okay so this says if you
assume one-third less than one-third
corrupt and as long as you count
sufficiently many votes and here
sufficiently many means two-thirds then
you enforce uniqueness agreement at
every position so everything seems great
we have consistency as long as
two-thirds of the nodes are honest and
the consistency proof doesn't say depend
on the the proposer being honest right
they're good the only thing I'm using is
that honest people vote uniquely but the
drawback of this protocol is the
liveness depends on this guy in the
center he has to continuously behave
like continue to behave honestly for the
protocol to make progress like if the
guy in the center he drops off line he
stops making proposals no progress will
be made if he starts making different
proposals to different people then
everyone will vote on different things
and nothing will collect enough votes so
the protocol will come to a heart in
that case - okay so essentially now the
goal is to to strengthen the protocol
such that liveness doesn't need the
stronger conditioning like we want to be
able to obtain liveness only assuming
2/3 honest without having to rely on the
guy in the center and how do we do that
so this is where most of these classical
Prodicus get somewhat complicated just
at a very high level the way these
classical protocols like pbft paxos and
at the variants the way they work is
that there are two different modes of
operation there's normal path which is
kind of just like what I talked about
but typically the voting has to continue
for a couple more rounds to kind of get
ready for the recovery path but it
doesn't matter like basically they are
just voting in a normal path and let's
see when the proposer becomes corrupt or
he crashes and then the system goes to a
recovery path where people try to reach
consensus and switch to the next
proposal so when they want to switch to
the next proposal they have to kind of
finalize the lock that they have already
agreed on like because we may be
operating at different paces like your
log can be a little bit longer than mine
so we reach agreement on that and we
then are switch to the next proposer so
this part actually requires for
consensus I mean in some sense because
here like we only have consistency right
we don't we don't actually have liveness
because lightness depends on the the guy
in the center being honest but here we
want to essentially solve consensus
problem in four and that's why this part
gets like kind of involved and I don't
have a good mathematical definition but
I guess not notes would agree that this
normal path protocol is fairly simple
it's just like it's very natural you you
vote you propose you vote you reach
agree
okay so when you implement these systems
the undesirable thing is that most of
the time your system should be operating
in this mode but if you look at the code
base like most of the complication is
here that's where all the bugs are and
that's where all the annoyance come from
so now like from a practical perspective
it would be really nice if we can't get
just full-fledged consensus but perhaps
just as simple as normal path that I've
shown like some very natural voting
protocol but we get both consistency and
lightness assuming 2/3 so how do we do
that
I'm just going to take this normal path
protocol that I've mentioned I'm going
to make a couple of tweaks to the normal
pad protocol and I'm going to show that
it gives you for consensus and the
couple tricks I find them quite natural
but I'm going to try to explain it to
see if you guys can find it natural to
okay
so what I want to say is like the ideas
I'm talking about is kind of there's a
line of work that you know some of which
came out of the crypto community that's
been developing these ideas gradually
all these protocols look very different
but I'm just trying to break you know
I'm trying to you know maybe simplify
things to the best I can
so the first relevant paper actually
this passport is a this metallics
Vitalik and Virgil virtues
this finality gadget like they want to
use this on top of the etherium
proof-of-work chain to periodically
which finality stronger finality and
then there's a subsequent works that
also kind of follow this paradigm like
hot stuff is the first work that proved
both consistency and lightness and the
product I'm going to talk about today is
closest to Paulo which is kind of a
improvement at work hard stuff
okay ten German should also denote
something yeah I guess I'm just confused
about Enderman because they had an
earlier version that was actually
sequential composition of one shot but
maybe later they change version or
whether it's a direct blocking
construction okay and so just to really
revisit like I like I said this is the
blockchain format the block format we
are going to assume it's kind of modern
cuz it's a chain right every node refers
to the parents hash I'm going to change
the sequence number to epic number and
we will see what this means and then
there's the payload which is the
transactions so imagine all these nodes
they have clocks and that tipped let's
say every second you can carried of this
assumption before now let's just
simplify things and as young people have
clocks and every epoch let's just assume
it's one second and we can assume the
network is synchronous so we can make a
round trip within a second like when it
I and I exchange messages the round trip
can always end in one second
this is just like some tedious setup
they're very different than the DFG in
Texas way
I mean people have tea Paxos that this
Cheney idea is not essential to PBF camp
axis every message takes policy I will
get rid of the assumption later so so
let's start by assuming synchronous but
in the end after I show you the proof
I'm actually going to tell your look the
proof doesn't rely on synchrony the
consistency proof doesn't rely on
synchrony yeah for now just for
simplicity like I don't want to
introduce partial partial synchronous
yet I'm going to explain exactly what is
partially synchronous after I show the
consistency proof so like you know
earlier we had the problem like when the
proposer is corrupt we want to switch
proposer so now we just want to do it
more aggressively we want to say you
know the protocol is going to continuing
epochs and every epoch allows you to
switch proposal so if we can do that
then we don't need a separate path for
proposal switch right so for simplicity
we can assume in round I I mean sorry in
epoch I epoch is different from round
right epoch can contain multiple runs
it's a one round trip can be implemented
in one epic
so in epic I note I is going to be the
proposer so this is publicly known we
can support other proposal rotation
policies but for now let's stick to the
simple one okay we need to know what's
the notion of freshness for a block or a
chain and this definition is very
natural like if the block and remember
the block encodes the epoch number if
the epoch number is larger than the
block is fresher and you can define the
notion similarly for a chain right
because because this is like a hash
chain a block actually just uniquely
binds to the to the entire prefix so in
some sense blocks and changed our kind
of analysis of each other so if you can
define
freshness for a change just by looking
at the last block of the chain
okay so I'm going to describe a protocol
that's just almost the same as before
like in every a proposal will propose
and everyone will vote and then when you
collect enough votes you confirm with
the couple tweaks where you check like
an additional condition when your vote
okay so in this product I'm going to
show like if everyone were honest then
things would be nice then you would see
exactly just a chain like this where the
epitome will increment for every block
but like in real life as we said some
notes can be corrupt or remember now
every epoch people are rotating to be
proposer
like for instance if the second guy is
just crash then he may not make any
proposal so we actually have to allow
the chain two skip skip epochs so we no
longer require that the epic numbers are
continuous in the chain we would be
happy as long as the epic numbers like
strictly increase but you can skip epics
like sometimes you may see Forks that
say in this case both chains and
otherwise so I'm going to introduce like
how to deal with such Forks at this
moment it's not important yet okay any
questions
so here's just like some other tedious
assumptions I have to mention we are
going to assume like the honest nodes
are receiving messages from the network
and for every message that's fresh
I'm just going to echo it to everyone
like so if I see something now you'll
see it in the next next round okay if I
see it now you'll see it soon like
within one daughter with one daughter
where that is maximum now our delay okay
and so like the messages we receive
right there are their blocks their
proposals blocks or votes so I can
locally maintain like every block that
has been notarized and since these
blocks have parent pointers like I can
reconstruct the chain on my local node
and imagine I will keep track of the
freshest notarized chain I've observed
in every round like if I ask a node you
know what is the freshest notarized
chain you have seen in round five he's
able to answer that question so yeah
sorry notarized again is like every
block in the chain has to have 2/3 votes
from distinct people so in the product
I'm going to describe every epoch the
proposals will the proposal will make a
proposal people will vote and if the
block collects 2/3 votes it becomes
notarized
but notarized doesn't mean final in this
protocol so you want to be a little bit
more patient I cannot just confirm like
in the earlier protocol I talked about I
immediately confirmed the block once
it's notarized but here you want to just
be a little more patient ok but the
definition of notarize is still the same
as before just 2/3 votes from distinct
people
any questions
[Music]
okay so here's essentially the protocol
the blue part is kind of the the change
or there are two tricks this is the
first weaken and then there is the
second tick okay so the protocol
progresses in epochs every effort is a
second at the beginning of the second if
I'm the designated proposal of the epoch
I will propose the next block so I need
to decide which chain to extend it from
and very naturally I want to pick the
freshest notarize chain I've seen and
the extent the new block from the
freshest notarize chain so I'm just
going to send this proposal to everyone
because the block contains the hash of
the parent block like everyone knows
where the block is extending from so now
people when they receive the proposal
they're going to vote and there are a
couple sanity checks like for instance
when I received the block I want to make
sure the block extends from a valid
chain right it cannot be like a dangling
block where the parent pointer points to
nothing and not only so I want to make
sure the parent block is notarized like
I've already received enough votes for
the parent block
okay so making sure the plug proposed is
standing from an authorized block the
notable vote for each epoch is the same
as before as the this simple protocol I
talked about earlier I don't want to
vote twice in the same epoch and the
last condition which is a little bit
subtle this is the new condition I want
to make an additional check now when I
vote but this check is also intuitively
it's also very natural because if the
less so essentially what I'm checking is
that the parent block must be fresh
enough but because if the proposal
proposer is corrupt he can try to throw
away all of the work that people have
found in the middle and tried to like
now it's already epic 100 but he tries
to extend from epic one and that's
obviously not okay right because now
other work in the middle is like thrown
away so I just want to make sure this
this parent block is reasonably fresh
like it's some block that was notarized
recently in the past and not too long
ago so precisely Wood is fresh enough
like you can define it precisely I'm
going to check that the parent block is
at least as fresh as the freshest
notarize chain I've seen not right now
but just a little while ago at the
beginning of the previous epic to check
fresh I'm basically comparing with my
own view but I don't want to compare
with my own view right now because maybe
the proposals network is just a little
bit slower than mine and I don't want to
kill liveness just because you know this
proposal is honest he's now he's a
little bit behind mine so his view is a
little behind mine so I'm going to
compare the proposers proposed block
with what I have observed just a little
while ago let's say at the beginning of
the previous epoch the freshest notarize
chain I've seen is at a patent then I
will insist that the proposal must
extend from a block of a patent or
larger cannot be smaller smaller means
to out maybe the guy is trying to throw
away a lot of work
has been tying them in the past okay I'm
only going to vote if this condition is
satisfied this additional condition is
satisfied this is confusing
you won't be able to remove the
something of a second but once we go
over the consistency proof for you you
can draw their conclusion whether
consistency requires synchrony so that I
think we can just go over the
consistency proof and you know see
liveness does require period of
synchrony
any question you're happy with something
this you've seen something notarized in
ten and you're happy with something
surprising in nine so that's in now it's
epic and somebody gives you something
alright at nine you're happy to vote on
it maybe we can be a little more precise
let's say now is a patan and I receive a
proposal proposal from you you're the
proposer the proposed though is
extending from a notarized block of epic
eight so I'm going to ask is this parent
block fresh enough and how do I
determine that I'm going to check okay
just a little while back at the
beginning of epic nine not now is epic
parent at the beginning of epic nine
what was the freshest notarized string
I've seen maybe it was up at seven then
that's okay because 8 is bigger than 7
but maybe a little while ago I've
already observed let's say I put nine oh
this is not not possible I guess I
claimed a bad example okay so let's say
now it's up at 10 and then you propose
some block to me and let's see it
extends from notarize block of epic five
and then so you propose some block of
epic 10 right this is the current
proposal so I received this I now ask
what was the freshest notarized chain I
had seen at the beginning of epic nine
okay
what is the freshest notarized chain
I've seen at the beginning of epic nine
which is currently it's up at pan okay
so maybe if the answer is if the answer
is six then I will reject the proposal
and not vote if the answer is five or
smaller I will say okay this proposal is
okay I'm going to vote on it it's fresh
enough
if it's tied in the same it decides to
be as fresh but actually you have a
uniqueness at every position if once
it's notarized so if it's a pack 5 it
must be the same block so ok so this is
the first peak and the second trick is
just basically when I consider a block
as final in this protocol like you want
to be a little bit more patient
notarized is not final yet because if
let's say block 3 is notarized the only
thing that says is that I know block 3
is notarized it could be like later on
like when this guy's makes a proposal it
extends from it skips a bunch of things
and extends from plug 2 right so if this
happens this notarized block is not
going to survive in the chain at the end
of time so we want to make be a little
bit more patient and here's the
finalization rule it's very similar to
Bitcoin right in Bitcoin I get my
longest chain I chop up the trailing six
blocks or chop up the trailing kappa
blocks
I don't consider the training kappa
blocks final but here I'm going to just
look at all the notarize chains I have
and if I ever observe three consecutive
blocks notarized three consecutive then
the first of the three up till here is
notarized so if I ever observe this okay
here are three that's consecutive
they're on otherwise so this prefix must
be final and here again I have three
consecutive blocks there are notarized
and I chopped up here and this whole
prefix is final okay so that's just
that's the whole protocol
to tricks to the normal burger I will
show a proof so first I will explain the
proof intuitively without any parameter
and then I'm going to plug in the
parameter so this three is actually the
dis protocol is a these parameters are
tunable like if you throw you some other
tricks to the protocol you can make the
three two I'm just going to try to do
what I think is the simplest
instantiation exactly that's why it's
called streamlined blockchain right you
can think of it there's something go
shot consensus and typically these
single these constant around single-shot
consensus protocols work by voting you
but you have to vote for multiple times
so let's say you take a single shot
consensus the first round of voting is
called prepared the second round of
voting is called commit like now I'm
going to use the next blocks
notarization to serve as the previous
blocks commit voting round so that's how
these things are obtained
okay so so why does this work I mean the
idea here is that I just want to be a
little bit more patient because like I
said if this block is notarized it
doesn't mean they'll get picked up later
like it could be dropped like maybe this
guy didn't see this notarization early
enough before he made the proposal so
then then it gets gets lost at the end
of time so I only want to find the nice
things and that I'm sure will not get
lost at the end of time and how can I be
sure of that I want to make sure many
people have seen the block notarized
early enough right so in this case many
people have voted four because four got
notarized it must be that many people
have seen three notarizing epic four
because I'm not going to vote on
remember the protocol I'm not going to
vote on this block unless it extends
from a notarized parent okay so if many
honest people have seen three notarized
and early enough let's say in there up
at four then later on if this guy tries
to cheat and not pick up block three
then they are just going to refuse to
vote like all these people will say okay
you're not proposing from a fresh enough
parent but you are trying to drop others
working in the middle I'm not going to
vote for your proposal right so waiting
a little bit longer waiting for the next
couple of blocks to also get in
otherwise makes sure essentially many
people have seen this block notarized
and not only so and they have seen it in
other eyes early enough okay so again in
this picture like all the dark blue
blocks and notarized and the light color
ones sorry all the dark blue ones are
final
everything is notarized but the dark
blue ones are final and the light color
ones are not final okay so how do I turn
this intuition into a formal proof
so first just recall I guess maybe I'll
run over for five to ten minutes and
your guys kind of if you want to go to
lunch you can leave a little really
okay so first every epic can only have
one unique notarize block and this was
proven in the first part of the talk
using the CERN pigeonhole principle okay
just keep that in mind so in this
specific example there are some on
essentially the parameters are
instantiated later but for now as I said
many people the sprockets notarize it
must be that many people have voted for
it
right and then the honest notes are only
going to vote for this block in their
epic four and they're only going to vote
for it if they have seen three
notarizing epic four so this means many
honest people have seen three notarizing
epic four and all of these honest people
later on if they receive a proposal from
the sixth proposer and this guy tries to
drop this block like he didn't he
doesn't pick up this block then all
these guys are going to refuse to vote
here and then such a bad proposal will
not get notarized so that's how the
proof is going to work it's kind of easy
to just plug in the parameters if four
is notarized there is a set s containing
at least two-thirds and minus F honest
notes right because notarized means
two-thirds votes among them at most F
come from corrupt notes the rest must
all come from honest notes
so all these honest notes have voted for
block three in their app for it means
they have seen block three notarizing up
for so later on all these notes s if
some time makes a bad proposal that
tries to drop this block or disguising
as will refuse to vote and if you do the
math if all these guys refuse to vote
how many notes can actually end up
voting for the dis bad bad proposal it
would be an over 3 plus F and F is less
than 1/3 so that's not enough to make a
notarization
so such a bad proposal is never going to
get notarized ok so this is still proof
for this picture I guess I won't go over
this but you can't just plug in general
parameters like this can be any e up of
e e + 20 + 2 and a prime y prime plus 20
primer so the same proof but like this
proof go over it very quickly whenever
there are three consecutive efforts with
honest proposals you make progress and
the only thing you have to show here is
that the only danger here is that people
won't vote on the undisguised proposal
and we just have to show that that's not
going to happen and this relies on the
fact so the only reason why people will
reject this proposal is because the
parent is not fresh enough and everyone
is comparing the proposals parent with
what they have seen just a little while
back right so all you have to show is if
I've observed this let's say block five
notarized a little while back at the
time you make a proposal you also must
have seen block five notarized - so you
cannot make an unfresh proposal if you
are honest so that's just I won't go
into details of the proof but that's
just like this is a pretty simple proof
ok so now I will try to wrap up fairly
quickly but here is a good time to
revisit the run complexity question
earlier I've assumed that the proposal
rotation policy is like one two three
four five six so if the adversary is
honest he can corrupt you know winter
and continuous proposals and you would
have to wait for linear amount of time
for confirmation but you've had you
selected the proposal around
imagine you pick a hash function like in
the beginning adversary decides who to
corrupt and I pick a random hash
function and every epoch I'm just going
to use this random hash function to
select who's the designated proposer and
in this case you only have to wait for
expect a constant number of epochs for
this condition to occur and therefore
you can reach confirmation you expect a
constant number of runs
assuming that corruption is static in
other words this hash function has to be
chosen after the adversary decides who
to corrupt you know if it's adaptive
corruption you can achieve the same but
by adding a little more complication to
the so the protocol I am NOT going to
show how to do how to achieve the same
with the adaptive corruption okay so
maybe I can't just try to conclude at
this note I'm partial synchrony and I'll
skip the rest one thing to observe like
you may want to think about this a
little longer to realize this before
eventually if you start the consistency
proof will lie enough you'll realize the
consistency proof doesn't rely on any
synchrony assumption at all but the only
thing you're assuming is that people's
epochs are increasing like my apple can
never decrease
secretly without secretly reaching yeah
in the partially synchronous model you
can reach consensus so this is yes
exactly the interesting thing is the
consistency proof doesn't rely on
synchrony but the light is proof relies
on synchrony because I have to the only
way I can make progress is if the honest
proposer is going to propose something
extend from some parent that's not to
out and to make make sure that guarantee
is respected whatever I know now you
must be able to know a little bit just a
little bit later yes so Lyman is proof
realized on synchrony whenever there are
three consecutive unease proposers
progress will be made as long as when
you propose the block the parent is not
too out and this can be ensured if let's
say whatever I see now you're going to
see a little bit later so that's the
only place where the synchrony
assumption is used okay so this actually
brings us to actually you know we can my
claim we can actually just this is a
protocol that works in the paschal
asynchronous model and partial synchrony
was a really beautiful model defined by
the word lynch and stockmeyer that there
are two versions of it I'm going to
focus on the GST version so in the in
this version of partial synchrony the
protocol receives an estimate of the
narrow delay that's it I estimate
messages will get delayed in half a
second and I'm going to let the protocol
know that when I run the protocol it
could be that the actual narrower delay
is much much longer that you know
sometimes I kept petitioned you know the
message takes an hour to deliver it's
much longer than what I had estimated up
front but it doesn't matter that when
the narrow gets partitioned and
everything we want to make sure the
protocol will still respect consistency
but it could be the liveness will star
when the stouter assumption is violated
because for instance if the narrow gate
tradition of course retinol you can
stack their economic progress or you're
always waiting to collect enough votes
but people cannot keep us both cannot
reach you because they're isolated in an
hour okay and then the protocol will
make progress as soon as you reach a
period of synchrony let's say as long as
at some point the starter assumption is
respected then during that period you're
going to start making progress but up
front the protocol doesn't know when the
period of synchrony is going to happen
like it could happen now it could happen
later this afternoon I have no idea so
that's the model in this model it turns
out that one third is the best you can
defend against so the protocol I talked
about is also actually tight in terms of
resilience for partial synchrony this
well-known theorem the proof is very
short maybe Raphael can talk about it in
the afternoon so just to summarize
streamlined block chains you know I want
to kind of get the full-fledged
consensus just by the proposed vote
paradigm it's always proposed for
proposed vote proposed vote confirm
confirm confirm and the reason why we
don't need a separate path for view
change or for view changes also another
name for the recovery path the reason
why we don't need that is because now
every epoch essentially allows you to
switch proposer and from a technical
perspective actually what enables this
streamlined approach is this is taking
everything apart you need a very simple
full-fledged consensus protocol to
implement the view change and once it
becomes really really simple you can
kind of sneak it in there and make
everything streamlined and in comparison
with like protocols of the past like
pbft paxos like I think if I would have
said these previous protocols implied
the in some sense if you take it apart
the view change has N squared bandwidth
but here we are actually implicitly
using a view change protocol that's
linear in bandwidth but what I want to
say is like in practice the the
bandwidth of the view change I don't
think it's like the most important thing
because view change action should not
happen very often right it's it only
happens when the current proposal is 40
it only happens in rare occasions but
what is really important I think is the
simplicity of the protocol like for
practical implementation and I think
yeah we should have you know ideally we
should have a unified protocol that's
what you want to implement also what do
you want to teach and I don't know if
this is there yet but we can move
towards that direction and I'm just
going to skip the rest of the talk you
can't you can't get better resilience in
the synchronous model following exactly
the same paradigm like this is the whole
protocol we have with some other tricks
you can achieve additional robustness
and performance properties I don't want
to go into the details there
[Music]
[Applause]
it's election
[Music]
like the vid requires some secret it's
kind of like formal approval is
directing us like we have somebody
construction because I hear you need
three consecutive ethics I guess you
have